bro uzi putting this 24 million oh my
god what the [ __ ]
is the deal with that tell me tell me
what the deal i saw a whole bunch of
tweets about it this morning but i
couldn't really figure out
this is literally just full pink diamond
implanted into his forehead yeah so you
can't even see it
this is crazy this is crazy
24 million dollar diamond
implanted in his head ow
why ow
so you can't even see it
oh so what's the point
what is the point i don't know
it like gives them energy or it's like
sort of anime
uh yeah i don't know it's like an anime
thing to do
or something it's like a sailor moon
type thing
i couldn't even say but yeah maybe
i mean you got inspired off anime i have
no clue
24 million dollars too
see that's why someone's gonna someone's
gonna
rob him and tear this [ __ ] out of his
phone yeah so someone tweeted a gif of
[ __ ]
uh thanos from avengers taking
what's-his-face is diamond out of his
forehead see that's the diamond oh there
it is right there so you got you you can
actually see it yeah no it's not that
tiny ass thing it's that big ass joint
right there
it's kind of cool i mean it's weird as
[ __ ] but like
as for a body mod it's like kind of cool
bro that's why old money
is wack like old billionaires don't even
deserve their money because they don't
even do cool [ __ ] with their money
they just buy like planes and boats and
go on vacation like that's the most
give give uzi a billion dollars see what
crazy [ __ ] he does
you'll get a car made of diamonds you
know what i mean like yeah
yeah they're creative okay
this is definitely creative yeah i was
gonna say rappers and like new money are
creative with how they blow their
[ __ ] cash
play this just this in the booth
oh man that freaks me the [ __ ] out
but people do weird or [ __ ] to their
bodies what i'm saying like the split
tongue [ __ ] and like the
even like gauges i feel like like big
gauges kind of freak me out more than
this
yeah i don't know that's pretty wild i
mean it goes into your skull but
it's it's here and there that's crazy
yeah bro rappers and new money they they
need to get
all the money you know yeah take jeffy
did you see blueface wrapped his entire
house in like camo
oh no it's [ __ ] crazy
like bape style camo his
whole house looks like that see [ __ ]
awesome that's what i'm saying yo yeah
see i see what you're saying now
rappers they they do cool [ __ ] with
their money
that's why people want to be rappers
boring [ __ ] yeah they
buy compounds and they do it but it's
like the same shit's like
yeah nice landscaping couple lakes
whatever ponds
personal bodies of water boring who
gives a [ __ ]
yeah at this face
painted his house blue camo look at that
look at that and look at he's cheesing
about it look at this [ __ ]
this is my house yeah cause it's like
kid stuff it's like what would you do if
you or
if you asked an eight-year-old what he
would do if he had a billion dollars
he'd be like i want to put a diamond in
my face
and i want to wrap my entire house into
blue camo
yeah modern billionaire they they try to
like build companies and rocket ships
and stupid-ass [ __ ] like that
no yeah no like roar kitty he should
have took his 48 million
and wrapped his house in [ __ ] cat
print
yeah or just something you know just
like melvin in the melvin capital logo
[Laughter]
this is melvin kaepernick now i am
melvin captain i am melvin capital now
nah yeah he should have what were they
saying that he should have he should
have bought the old melvin capital
building and opened a gamestop
no they should have bought the the guy
who owns melvin capital
or like the managing partner or whatever
he has like a 40 million dollar miami
mansion
or something he should have just bought
the mansion and torn down the house and
just put a game stop right
[Laughter]
yeah like little uzi's got this crazy r8
the
rap is insane on it the paint
yeah it's like beige or what is it i
remember seeing no it's
like something i think it's some anime
characters wrapped on under the car oh
right right right right you got a couple
different wraps in the car
anime and [ __ ] he says his bio says
asian on the inside i think
a word on instagram i was just looking
at this today because i was trying to
find some
it says asian on the inside
yeah they uh um
picked up 20 million bucks on a diamond
like
i mean i guess it would it was that a
good investment is it a bad investment
i don't think it matters to him here's
his uh
r8 right here that's pretty wild
it's crazy i know we gotta do more [ __ ]
like this dude
i know just [ __ ] absurd
money on stupid [ __ ] yeah that's that's
way cooler
at least it keeps you young a little bit
you know why don't we get something
implanted into us
[Laughter]
just take all the [ __ ] podcast
earnings for one year and share a
diamond between our forehead
doesn't have to be a diamond it could be
a 10d or something like that okay
oh what about because we can't do
diamonds what about a
a tendy shaped from glass or something
you know like a sculptured oh yeah yeah
i see what you're saying yeah like a
pendant like a nice
like a tindy rocket ship for the new
stew
and like you could become like a you
know a relic in the background
oh like oh we don't implant it this is
just a statue it's just
yeah it's just a thing i like that we
gotta we definitely gotta do more [ __ ]
like that with the new
with the new studio and the new office
you were talking body mods what the hell
body mods are we gonna do
that's what i'm saying that's i mean uh
synthol
right into our ass cheeks yeah big ass
let's do synthol ass injections
get that big cake get that big ass cake
dude that'll feel like sitting on a
water bed at all times
i want a fat booty dude i want a big fat
ass i look good with some big
giant wagon on me
you know you know that that russian dude
that has synthol in his arms is like a
tick-tock star
yeah yeah and like he hasn't died yet
somehow
somehow he's got so much synthol bro
like that has to get to your heart
eventually right um
does he have to have his like arms
amputated at some point
i don't know if i amputated but i think
something bad will happen
most definitely yeah it's kind of it's
got to be
bad in the long run let's see long-term
side effects of synthol
i mean amputation is definitely one of
them because it cuts off
like the flow of blood or just normal
uh body functioning
yeah um
oh this [ __ ] can cause nerve damage oh
it's [ __ ] up
would not would not recommend
cerebral stroke yeah hell no dude
you